Daniel: Hello and welcome everyone.
This is March 31, 2020, three's quarterly
roundtable number one from the Active
Inference Institute.
Welcome to the active inference
institute.
We're a participatory online institute
that is communicating, learning and
practicing applied active inference.
You can find us at the links on this
slide.
This is a recorded and an archived
Livestream, so please provide us feedback
so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome and we'll be following video
etiquette for live streams.
Today we're going to be checking in with
our regular quarterly roundtable series.
We're going to first provide some updates
from the institute scale.
Then we'll talk about ongoing education
and research projects before concluding
with some thoughts on the institute's
paths in the coming year.
So first, would the two of you like to
introduce yourself?
I'm Daniel, I'm a researcher in
California and also the president of the
institute.
Alex?
Alex: Yes.
Hi.
My name is Alex.
I'm vice president of the institute and
also educator and systems thinker.
Please go ahead.
Bleu: Hi.
I'm Blue Knight.
I'm an independent research consultant in
New Mexico and the secretary for the
active inference institute.
Back to you, Daniel.
Daniel: Awesome.
Well, let's begin with some views on the
institute at the organizational scale.
First, just as a summary overview put us
off to the side, we engage with our niche
and provide services to it on multiple
fronts.
Here, who we are and what we are is
reflected visually at the institute
scale.
We have several groups, including the
ones that we'll be describing in the
coming slides.
The board of Directors, the officers and
the scientific advisory board.
We have two organizational units,
somewhat like departments.
These organizational units help support a
wide range of projects related to
education and research.
Any general comments that you'd like to
add?
Alex: Yeah, let me add here that yes, we
are using it's kind of simple schema, but
it actually represents our vision to have
this hierarchical structure explicit and
represent in our attempts to align with
active inference approach or
organizational side of our activities.
So here we have connections to the niche
and different scales of institution in
general units projects.
We are having intention on keeping a
structure alive and see how which
affordances provide us to development.
Daniel: As we undergo morphological
development.
And just to give a bit more information
on the governance, the board of directors
serves to implement institute scale
formal strategy and governance they
specified and provide oversight for the
officers who are closer to the day to day
operations at the institute.
And the board of directors applies active
inference at the organizational scale.
In contrast and in complement, the
scientific advisory board assists with a
wide range of tasks to reflect their
diverse backgrounds and approaches.
So let's talk a little bit more about the
Bod and the SAB.
First, as to the board of directors, our
2022 to 2023 board of directors are
listed here and we've recently confirmed
three of us here on this stream as the
officers again close to the day to day
operations and who one is speaking with
most likely when they email the
Institute.
Currently we are working towards our
nonprofit tax exemption status 501 C
three status for our nonprofit and we
continue to highlight bolts dimensions,
business, operational, legal, technical
and social.
Anything else that either of you would
like to add about our formal
organizational structure?
Alex: Let me possibly add here that on
the process of development it was like
needed legally activities to have all
these people, all these roles for the
legal structure of Institute and that's
great, so great people we have on board
and from the site.
As I said, even having a team of this
size, the process and structure became
more complex and all such changes took
more time to restructuring.
And like for first quarter we started
this process like last year and even
first quarter we'll need it to finalize
these activities.
But that's great that we are here now
having people in our roles and having
accordance to legal requirements and now
we can make next steps, possibly will
take again a lot of time, but it's kind
of new forum and the speed of such
changes on Institute scale takes more
time.
Daniel: Thank you.
It was definitely a memorable moment when
during a scientific advisory board
meeting, one member suggested that this
was stretching the upper limit of how
complex and complicated our organization
should be at our stage and another
contrasted that it was actually the
minimal level of complexity required to
pursue certain legal statuses and other
work.
So we're kind of straddling that line
riding forward.
We have the second cohort of our
scientific advisory board in full swing
already.
Most have joined meetings or engaged in
other activities.
We have a healthy number of returning
advisory board members and some great new
advisory board members.
So thank you all for your work in the
scientific advisory board and we're
looking forward to bringing forth your
engagement in the coming year in many,
many ways.
Anything either of you would like to add
here?
Alex: Maybe I have to mention about kind
of diversity in terms of people from
different domains and it's growing in the
number of participants.
Maybe it even looks like much more people
when needed.
But having opportunity to discuss
relevant questions for research,
different research fields and to have
different sites, it's totally valuable
for us and provide us opportunities to
make right steps in needed directions
related to research site mostly for
sure.
Daniel: Thank you.
There are many ways to engage with the
Institute.
There's a lot of asynchronously available
materials like the recordings of the live
streams and other productions and the
transcripts and so on, things we'll
discuss more about.
And also for those who want to get more
involved, be active infra ants.
There are multiple opportunities for
action in the volunteer program by going
to our website and under education
finding Volunteer you can support your
engagement with one or as many projects
and activities as you'd like.
By registering as a volunteer, we'll keep
you in the loop about specific
affordances for your participation.
For example, registration, opening for an
upcoming learning group or some cool new
update with a given project.
And for those who are looking for even
more structure, we offer an internship
program.
We have currently about ten active
inference from around the world who are
engaging with different research and
education affordances at the Institute in
their own ways, reflective of their own
situations.
The interns engage in some element of
learning and education, usually with
textbook groups or other courses, some
element of project based learning where
they are going to be and are contributing
to different projects, making
translations in the ontology or
developing some other kind of work.
And the internship has a more active
mentorship and peer facilitation aspect
for whatever your educational and
research journeys are.
Any comments on that?
We hope that this becomes a very
important vector for people who want to
catalyze their active inference journey.
We basically cannot imagine a better way
for someone who wants to dedicate 1 hour
per week, 10 hours per week, 30 hours per
week, whatever it may be.
We can find a kind of relationship that's
going to be mutually beneficial.
Alex: Yeah, I think it was quite a smart
mutation for our activities and having
that format and having that actually
active people in game, it's the most
valuable thing.
And having organizing it as flexible as
possible around people specific situation
and learning paths, we can keep it and
develop and hopefully it will bring more
people who are interested in active
inference to some actual activities and
learning path in that direction.
Daniel: Great.
With respect to what they call social
media, we have our main platforms and
numbers noted here, so it's been great to
see continued growth on these fronts.
As to the big picture on our activities,
the above link provides an always updated
reference point for the activities that
are ongoing and the times of their
meeting and also links to those documents
if you want to learn more.
And we're going to go through many of
them today.
But first, just the 30,000 foot view.
These are some of the active activities
at the Institute, all of which are
participatory so if you're curious, just
wanting to know more or see a way for you
to contribute or maybe even want to spin
up your own project where you'd be a
facilitator, we can talk more about it.
As for learning groups, we continue to
have Par et al.
Textbook groups which will be discussed
later.
We have been active with Sanjiv Namjoshi
in the Fundamentals of Active Inference
Group, working on Sanjiv's book in
progress and providing feedback which
will hopefully be surfaced more and
throughout the year and also to be
addressed later.
We're working on category theory as a
learning group.
We organize and produce live streams and
with the transcripts of those live
streams, publish an archive and do other
things.
With the language Processing in Active
Inference Project we're developing
implementations for active inference at
this point, largely using approaches and
code that are scattered elsewhere,
bringing them together and help making it
more coherent for people who want to
engage in active inference modeling.
So people who want to engage with the
actual code and see how it works in a
script rather than from a mathematical or
from a philosophical approach.
This is a great project to add into your
toolkit in robotics and embodied.
JF.
Cloudier continues to present us with
progress on his work in symbolic active
inference and engage participants in this
very exciting area.
In the active inference ontology, we
continue to develop translations,
definitions, examples and counterexamples
and methodologies involving the active
inference ontology and how it's used.
And we also have several open hours per
week in our discord where we have wide
ranging conversations.
These are really great entry points if
someone doesn't even find a specific
project that they're curious about but
they just want to learn more.
In general, joining any open discussion
hour is a great option because we can
field that conversation then.
And just to show a few of our seed or
inactive projects starting in May, we'll
have a Physics as Information Processing
course by Chris Fields.
We'll talk more about that in a few
minutes.
Podcast continues to exist, albeit a
little bit on the back burner in
software.
We have several software ideas and
projects that have been sketched to some
extent but are not engaging regularly to
meet, as well as the development of
frameworks for cognitive agent modeling
and course development.
So we have a good portfolio for those who
choose to engage with one or more
activity, and there are always burners
that are on low or off.
Let's go into the educational project
updates in the Edgy ActInf
organizational.
Alex: Yeah.
Related to education.
As we can see now, educational activities
became more and more important and
active, and we have different formats and
even outlining some creation and
organization of different educational
courses.
And it's also a result of transformation
to institute when we consider this
educational function as specific for such
type of organizations.
And for now, we kind of believe we see
the results of implementing such
strategy, starting to think about
education and starting to make actions to
have education in place in institute.
Daniel: Thank you.
Currently, as one of our primary
educational avenues, we are continuing
with our textbook group centered around
the Par, Pazulo and Friston 2022
textbook.
So the first cohort has been completed
last year, and those who have completed
the cohort are encouraged to join future
cohorts and be participants again or be
learning assistants.
The second cohort, which began in the
second half of last year, is about two
weeks from finishing the whole textbook,
and the third cohort, which begun in
2023, is now closing in on finishing the
first half of the textbook.
Cohort four will begin with the beginning
of the textbook in the coming months.
So check out on our website, the textbook
group page, if you want to register for
the fourth cohort or if you have any
other questions.
Just to summarize, it's a really exciting
and inclusive experience to be in the
textbook group.
People have all backgrounds, different
familiarities and angles of approach to
active inference.
Everybody has different familiarity with
the active inference ontology and with
equations, math, statistics, philosophy,
all these threads that come together in
the textbook group, we have fun and we
work together to improve our shared
documents so that we can have a wide
variety of tools and augmented learning
approaches that we wouldn't be able to
have alone.
So if you're planning to work on this
textbook at all, or if you're curious
about it, there couldn't be a better way
to engage with it.
Um, moving to another educational project
with a small group of participants, we
are working on a category theory group.
This group is an extended zero
preparation session for this draft
dissertation thesis by Toby St.
Clair Smith mathematical Foundations for
a compositional account of the Bayesian
Brain.
And in this group, where we have many
different backgrounds and familiarity
with category theory ranging from none to
some, we are preparing the zero
background and context materials for
upcoming live streams with Toby in the
middle of 2023.
Where we're going to be discussing this
incredible work, which brings together in
some novel ways the compositionality of
category theory with the otherwise non
compositional Bayesian brain active
inference type approaches.
We're going to see how it all works
together in the coming years.
It's not the end with this dissertation,
it's really just the beginning.
And so it's been quite exciting to
develop educational materials as a small
group as well as some individuals within
the group developing personal materials
like blogs and syllabus to help learn at
the intersection of active inference and
category theory.
And everyone's welcome to get involved
with this group, just as with all the
others.
And this group is an example or a
template of how we operate.
Deliverable oriented learning groups at
the institute.
Doesn't mean every person is going to
have homework.
It's just the way that, for example,
shown here on the right, we structure
meetings and set a pace where we know we
could spend five years working on one
page, because that's what the PhD is
like.
But we also move quickly enough to get
things done in reasonable time frames and
have a shared niche.
Many pages not shown where we have notes,
questions, discourse and so on, anything
blue or alex.
On category theory.
Alex: Maybe not only here, but in general
for education and courses, I think that
we called value added services for
education, for course organization.
It's kind of unique because it's
evolving, but it's evolving around some
structure for ontological work and having
it in place like a ground.
We can build a lot of really valuable
services to provide additional
information, links, connections between
terms, ideas, questions and so on.
And I believe development and that
direction and trying to apply the same
approach for different educational
activity will bring interesting results
for everyone.
Daniel: Awesome.
Agreed.
We have recently been very happy to
announce that in May 2023, we will be
hosting a course taught by Chris Fields,
Physics as Information Processing.
You can find out more in the Education
section on our site.
It is going to consist of six lectures
live streamed by Chris Fields and six
live streamed but also participatory
discussion sessions with Andre Aguire.
So you'll be able to access all
materials, preparatory readings,
associated topics, recordings of live
streams and so on on this course.
Coda and look forward to learning more
about this.
It's going to be a great course.
Anything you want to add?
Bleu: I'm really looking forward to it.
That's all.
Super excited.
I think it's really like awesome of Chris
to put this forward and let us host this
wonderful class.
And yeah, we're going to be having
discussions sections that are hopefully
transcribed through the Active Inference
Journal.
So getting in touch and participating in
these sections is a good chance to
interact with the journal in that kind of
way.
That's the only addition I would make,
maybe yes.
Daniel: All the lectures and discussions
and asynchronously submitted questions
and answers will be compiled and
published and citable.
So this we expect to be a multi hundred
page functionally landmark publication.
If you're interested in this area and
you're in this moment in time, do what
you can.
Alex.
Alex: I just want to add that it's great
that we see that growing connections
between quantum theory and quantum
information theory to ActInf inference
and it's starting to grow and it brings
us more and more first principles into
framework basements.
It's very cool.
Daniel: Agreed.
We've had a very exciting 2023 for Live
Streams.
First just the ask.
With your contributions and assistance,
we can co create a special and engaging
sequence of Live Streams for the rest of
the year.
So everybody listening is welcome to
join.
You're always welcome to comment and
continue the discussion.
Also, you can join Live Streams while
they occur.
You can self nominate.
If you'd like to give a presentation or
have your paper discussed, please let us
know.
Or if you have a recommendation or even a
warm introduction that could go a long
way.
If you'd like to bring some materials and
perspectives really to the forefront, you
can collaborate on a zero background and
context video and help lock in the ways
that you might want to share background
for a topic to preempt uncertainty or do
any other kind of service in the
epistemic niche.
And we meet weekly, of course, to discuss
these issues just quickly to look at some
of the streams that we've had in this
year 2023.
So far we had guest dreams from Adam
Peace alareza Moder, Shanti Avil, Gwen,
andy Clark, Jordan Hall and Matthew
Pikowski benjamin Fallon Days baba
Brinkman, Max Berg Shuji and Vanya Visa
So these guest streams ran the gamut from
consciousness to clinical psychiatric
modeling with active inference,
improvisation in rap, ecological
psychology, civics and governance,
physics of creation, technical details on
surprise definitions, integration of
large language models with neurosymbolic
approaches and formal ontologies.
And later today there will be an.org
stream with Stray Jane on Plural
Publics.
Those are the guest streams, and we've
also had a great set of other streams.
For paper oriented live streams.
We've had two series in live stream.
52 geometric methods for sampling,
optimization, inference and adaptive
agents.
Lance Acosta joined for both discussions
and has incredible insights into that
group's paper that brings together the
topics in the title and in the recently
concluded 53 sequence on a pair of
papers, Snakes and Ladders in
Paleoanthropology and To Copy or not to
Copy.
In both of these live streams we had the
authors Michael Walker, Hector Enrique
and Carl Friston joining, and both were
very special and illustrative
discussions.
We've had two model streams, one on
Pymdp.
A.
Python package for generative models of
the active inference flavor.
That was with Connor Hines and Carl
Friston.
And Tom Ringstrom joined for a
presentation.
Reward is not necessary.
We also enjoyed a sequence of bookstreams
and so I'll pass to Blue to say a little
bit more about those bookstreams.
Bleu: Sure.
So we have been going through this text
and discussing the material presented in
the first three parts of the book, and
we're not going to do the interviews at
the end section of the book just because
it's kind of beyond the scope of what we
wanted to cover in the bookstream.
But we have been going through week by
week, chapter by chapter, examining this
material, which is really the application
of active inference to governance,
especially with our own governance of the
institute, like being forming officers
and a board of directors and how should
we factor in the concept of active
inference into our governance policy.
So this was a very interesting group of
readings and discussions that we've had
over the last few weeks, and we are going
to have a final discussion coming up in
the next three ish weeks.
Hopefully the author will join us again
to discuss the material, but also this
discussion.
We would really love to have outside
perspectives for people that have been
engaging with this material, either
through watching the live streams or the
book streams or have read the text.
So if you want to get in on these
discussions of active inference and its
application and governance, please get in
touch because we would really like to
have some different perspectives in our
final discussion session.
Daniel: Thank you, Blue, and also to
Tyler for this great series and to kind
of conclude on the live streams and bring
in the journal, which is actually what
happens in the work itself.
Every live stream that we do, which can
be found at the Koda link shown here and
posted in every video description.
The slides are available where possible,
but also we are developing a utilities
pipeline that automatically downloads the
audio from YouTube, uses artificial
intelligence to do speech to text,
outputs a markdown and then uses
rendering approaches to render that
markdown.
And so there's a Git folder where you'll
find all the transcripts and therefore be
able to do some incredible natural
language analysis, ontology driven
analysis of this corpus of several
hundred videos and growing.
And we look forward to continuing to
improve that pipeline as speech and text
processing advance quite rapidly and
techniques and methods that were outside
of our capacity even weeks to months ago,
day by day draw nearer.
So if you'd like a really open,
decentralized science open science
project or corpus, there are many, many
ways in the journal that we can improve
the rigor, accessibility and
applicability of our live streams and
therefore continue to add value and
meaning even for live streams from the
past.
Anything to add?
All right.
Alex: I want to support that.
It give us a lot of opportunities to
reuse in some way this transcription from
our side institute building some possibly
language tools or chats to communicate
about active inference.
And a lot of opportunities will arise
like next months Andy Clark, which is
development of language models in general
as a domain.
So we have like a main piece of text and
how we will use this text, what services
we can create, to which cases we can
support.
It will be huge and hopefully people from
community of Institute could share some
ideas how we can improve here and
possibly participate in this project,
considering it as a technical heavy on
the frontier of current language
processing tools.
Daniel: Thank you, Alex.
Indeed, to watch all the videos may not
be possible.
Given limited time, it may not be
preferable but to engage in discourse and
synthesize summaries with a rich and
articulate corpus where speakers are also
known and we have connections with the
speakers and the co authors and all this
other kind of information, there are just
going to be many, many opportunities.
So hopefully in a future roundtable, we
can revisit this, go into a little bit
more depth and show the status of our
pipeline such that we can fulfill that
vision of having a live stream and then
rapidly within.
Hours after the live stream have gotten
the audio rendered into Markdown rendered
the Markdown into a variety of
accessibility oriented formats it's going
to be amazing.
In our last section we'll talk about some
research updates.
If you're watching Live, please feel free
to write a comment or share a favorite
memory or do so in the comments after the
video but we'll go through just a few
research updates and then if anyone has
questions in the live chat, address those
and then that'll be it for the
roundtable.
So, just a research overview.
We have a handful of ongoing research
projects.
In the active inference ontology, we are
developing the active inference
ontology.
In active blockprints, we are developing
a package that integrates and facilitates
approaches for computational modeling
with active inference.
And in robotics and embodied JF Cloudier
is leading the way on some Lego robots
that do symbolic active inference.
We have several seed research projects
for those who'd like to, for example,
explore a graphical interface for active
inference or look at the broader
mindscape of cognitive agent modeling
approaches.
And lastly, although most ramified in
their manifestations are the individual
research projects, so not all the work
that people are engaged in is necessarily
using the documents and the deliverables
of the institute.
We also really honor and want to support
the individual research journeys that
many are on inside or outside of formal
academic structures.
And so with our interns and others who
aren't even interns, there are so many
exciting projects that everyone is
engaged in.
They share during the open hours, they
post updates in our discord, and we do a
lot when we work on our own projects and
group projects.
Just to give two examples to highlight,
one of our interns, Shohe Wakayama, has
updated his paper on active inference for
autonomous decision making with
contextual multi armed bandits and this
has recently been accepted to relevant
conference.
So congratulations Shohe.
Also a variational synthesis of
evolutionary and developmental dynamics,
a paper with both I and Blue as co
authors, and some other names that people
may find familiar from the cast of live
stream characters.
So just a few that we wanted to draw
together but a little bit more
generally.
If you have any work that you'd like to
share, please let us know and we'll make
sure to highlight it in future
newsletters and roundtables.
It would be awesome to have that kind of
an update system so that we could
highlight like a collage or a mosaic of
all the works that people are doing
around the institute.
And it's just been great to see.
There are so many others that it was just
hard to pick exactly what ones in our
limited time to put here.
But we saw many great developments over
the past month personally and
organizationally.
So this is just a few of what the
research side looks like and in our last
minutes we can talk about whatever you
fellows would like in terms of next steps
or reflections.
Perhaps Alex first?
Alex: Okay, yeah, I think we will
continue structuring and improving
activities related to education,
supporting interest from community and
interest for people who can produce
educational materials.
We try to support in all direction and
provide affordances on organizational
side and possibly on communications and
for research.
I believe we will work on some kind of
research strategy with our scientific
advisory board because for now we have a
few core research projects ongoing and
it's great basics.
We support research of people who
contacted us, but having in place like a
long term strategy in research directions
will be a great achievement if we can
present something related on next
roundtable related to it.
That's all for my side.
Daniel: Thank you.
Bleu: Alex Blue so for me, I have kind of
pulled back if you're not seeing me
around discussing active inference, it's
because I have decided to prioritize
building institutional infrastructure and
institutional capacity for the active
inference institute.
So my focus now is on getting grants for
the institute and pushing on the 501
status, 501 three C, three C, three,
whatever it is, the nonprofit status.
So that's my biggest priority and focus.
And I'm looking forward to kind of
getting over a few of those hurdles and
getting back into the material because I
really do miss it and I really miss
hanging out with everyone, but I have to
focus my attention and effort so that I
can continue to focus on active inference
for many years to come.
Daniel: Awesome.
Great notes there.
Indeed, the organizational work is
applying active inference.
It looks a little different than reading
a paper.
Joining a textbook group search this
quarter has been very rewarding, very
developmental from what we can see.
It would be extremely helpful and
requested appreciated for those who
engaged a lot, all the way on down
through a little, or not at all to
provide their feedback directly or in the
comments to this video or however they
see fits, to let us know about how we can
improve.
You are our niche and we act in first
serve for you.
Having that kind of closure with even
your acknowledgments means a lot and it
does help shape what we can and do offer
on research.
Alex, I also look forward to what you
suggested about developing more of a
research program so that we can see where
different things fit and we're kind of
engineering that from the bottom up, but
increasingly being able to take a top
down view.
And about education, every textbook
group, every zero, every course is
rapidly becoming easier and easier to
organize as we develop templates,
expertise and so on.
And right now the rate limiting step in
those who want to create or engage with
educational material is the material
itself.
And so that feels like a really good step
in our active inference corner of the
world.
Prior there was a lack of content, not
saying that there's a sufficient amount
now, but hardly any casual conversations
existed and hardly any technical
discussions existed for especially this
cutting edge active inference
developments that truly on a month by
month basis, provide at least new views
on older discussions.
And so being able to develop that
material and increasingly support others
who want to teach.
Their own courses, like Chris Fields, as
well as others that will be announced and
upcoming in the rest of the year.
So those who want to teach or have a
hosted course, get in touch.
Those who want to learn more, we hope
you're doing so.
And again, we appreciate all of the
engagements and feedback.
It's how we actually make it happen
together.
Any closing thoughts?
Bleu: Just to express gratitude for
everybody engaging with the Institute,
keeping us alive, and for you guys,
because you're awesome to work with and
hang out with.
Daniel: It's been fun.
Alex: Thank you.
Daniel: Thank you, officers.
Thank you, participants.
Farewell.
Bleu: Bye bye.